Starfox the royal prince of titan brother of
thanos what do you want lads your friends are in
big trouble and we know where to find them welcome
back everyone this is going to be my eternals
deleted scene video for harry styles starfox
thanos and the alternate ending to the movie that
they just revealed which was going to originally
be way way darker than the ending we got in the
theatrical cut so there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i do marvel
videos every week but they just released eternals
on disney plus in a whole bunch of deleted scenes
so a lot of you probably been rewatching the post
credit scenes and bigger moments in the theatrical
version of the post-credits scene harry styles
and patton oswalt show up on the domo the eternal
ship here is starfox and pip the troll after druid
makkari and thena have been traveling through the
universe for weeks searching for response signals
from the other groups of eternals that were sent
to other celestial seed worlds in other galaxies
after introducing him as the prince of titan
brother of thanos starfox reveals he's another
prime maternal just like ajak was and just
like sersi became with a special celestial
core that allows him to communicate directly with
irish and the judge and tells them he knows what
happened to the other eternals he knows the
irish and the judge came to earth to take them
back to the world forge and he knows where to
find the world forge that's the place where
airshim the judge created all the eternals and
all the deviants but they just revealed way more
deleted scenes with starfox and originally they
had a bunch of extra backstory for him explaining
his character his relationship with thanos tying
in more with the backstory for titan that we got
during avengers infinity war that explains what
happened to titan and why it got destroyed and
the darker ending sort of ties in with what they
were doing with these extra hairy style scenes
like an empire strikes back avengers infinity war
style ending with a really hardcore downer moment
so i'll start with the deleted starfox scenes
first in the thanos titan backstory stuff and
then i'll talk about the alternate ending but
in the deleted scenes starfox is seen with the
other eternals while they're dressed in their
base layers before they've been sent to a new
celestial seed world the silver or grayish robes
that they all wear when they're being rebooted and
their minds are being wiped this is basically what
they look like between missions like they've been
doing this for millions of years going around
to different galaxies different celestial seed
worlds birthing new celestials and after each
new celestial is born no matter which group of
eternals you're talking about which galaxy you're
talking about they all go back to their ship and
they go back to these base layer robes and get
rebooted they go into hibernation as they're sent
to another world salma hayak actually revealed
that she was here filming these scenes with harry
styles when they were dressed in these robes
it sounds like they filmed more flashbacks for
harry styles character to explain his story when
he shows up in this version the theatrical cut
but also another version of the ending where harry
styles is with them when they're all being sent
to another planet to birth another celestial and
we would have seen harry styles starfox with his
original group of eternals traveling to titan
in more scenes of him with younger thanos and
the other eternals that were part of his group
of eternals the director explained that starfox
was originally part of a group of 10 eternals that
were sent to titan by heirs from the judge because
it's always a group of ten like that's why they
start with this group of eternals and there are 10
of them before ajak gets killed so starfox's group
of 10 eternals were sent to titan because titan
was another celestial seed world the director
didn't say which celestial was inside titan but
that was the idea and he also rebelled against his
group's mission just like sersi and the other main
group of eternals in this movie do except he was
not successful in saving titan he fled the planet
before it was destroyed rebelling against irishman
the judge i know it sounds like there's some
conflicting information between the story thanos
told about what happened to titan and what they
were going to say happened during the eternals
movie but in all these alternate starfox scenes
it's implied that the emergence on titan was the
reason it was destroyed i think that thanos story
about overpopulation in avengers infinity war
fits with the eternal's true mission to drive
overpopulation in order to speed up the emergence
if you think about it that way it's not as much of
a continuity issue each celestial needs to feed
off a certain amount of cosmic energy given off
by life on planets so the more people the faster
that happens in thanos said that he wanted to kill
half the population on titan to prevent that
from happening so the idea is that thanos also
probably learned about the emergence on titan and
tried to stop it by getting rid of half the people
you're not the only one cursed with knowledge so
this is a new way of contextualizing thanos plan
to balance half the universe it makes him seem
like more of an anti-hero than a total villain
like getting rid of half the population to stop
the celestials from creating more celestials and
i think that's why starfox also didn't try to stop
thanos earlier from snapping half of all life with
the infinity gauntlet like if starfox is another
prime eternal with this celestial core it means
he's crazy powerful but if starfox also rebelled
against airship the judge the way they explained
in this movie he also wouldn't have wanted to
stop thanos because it sounds like thanos also
had this grand plan to stop the celestials it's
just that thanos was going about it in the most
hardcore dark way possible i did a longer video
about how the eternals movie recontextualizes
thanos's plan making him seem like more of a hero
so i had a link for that in the description below
but the alternate ending the downer version of
the ending that the director said she originally
wanted to use started with the eternals failing
to stop the emergence on earth like tiamet would
have successfully been born burst out of the
earth destroying everything all the remaining
eternals would have survived and ajak would have
somehow survived or been repaired by heirs from
the judge and the movie would have ended with
them back in these gray robes being rebooted
and sent to another celestial seed planet
and the cycle would have started again
and it seems like they also shot a version of
that downer ending with them being rebooted again
with harry styles starfox character with them the
reasons why i think marvel didn't want to use that
version of the ending is one because it's super
depressing and two it would have raised too many
questions about the continuity because how could
they destroy earth and still say this was the
main mcu universe it would only make sense if the
events of the movie were happening in an alternate
universe and the eternals movie wasn't supposed to
be a big multiverse plot the way spider-man no way
home and doctor strange multiverse of madness are
multiverse movies there's just way too many cosmic
concepts and new mythology with the celestials in
the black knight that they were introducing in the
film and the eternals movie is supposed to take
place after the events of the shangshi movie which
itself takes place around the time spider-man
is getting doxxed by mysterio in spider-man far
from home like later in 2023 so the events of
spider-man no way home in hawkeye are currently
the latest we've been the furthest forward we've
been in the marvel phase four timeline because
they both end around christmas 2024 if that wasn't
clear if you do want to count the loki series yes
they do travel to the end of the timeline like
billions of years in the future but all this stuff
at the end of the eternals movie is happening
around the time that spider-man no way home is
picking up and there aren't really any easter eggs
for that during spider-man no way home like you
have to imagine on the other side of the planet
while this is getting started there's this giant
stone celestial showing up in the indian ocean
like wait a minute what you have to imagine jay
jonah jameson would be trying to blame timid on
spider-man somehow he would find some way to blame
spider-man for that and a lot of you have also
asked how starfox and thanos can be brothers and
the sons of a'lars and sui san on titan if they're
all eternals and all eternals are just celestial
robots who can't have children and how did starfox
become the prime eternal of their groupon titans
so just based on all these deleted scenes
and story lines that they've revealed they
imply that airshim the judge created starfox
group of eternals all 10 of them together
including thanos so the mcu version of thanos and
starfox were probably not born biologically the
children of allars and sweet sand the way they
were in the comics in their family in the same
way that all the eternals think of each other as
a hodgepodge family of sorts like the eternals
that we see during the movie all think of each
other as family but they're not biologically
related i think the red skull scene from avengers
infinity war where he's greeting thanos and gamora
actually backs this up because he says gamora
daughter of thanos and she was not born to thanos
like he was her adoptive father so when he says
thanos son of a'lars in the mcu at least it's
a little bit different and he's not saying that
they're biologically related i think they probably
just changed that part of their backstory just in
the name of simplicity for mcu continuity purposes
the reason why thanos looks like purple
space grimace with the nutsack chin
different from all the other eternals
from titan is because he carries the
deviant mutation but he's not a deviant himself
he's another eternal that just looks different
in the mcu the way they explain this is that
all the eternals are created to look similar
to the beings that inhabit the celestial seed
worlds that they get sent to they're just created
to blend in with whatever populations they go to
so that's why fastos looks different from makari
for instance all the others why they all speak
with different accents they were just created
to blend in when they get rebooted and sent to
a new planet they're just sort of reprogrammed
to blend in with whatever population is on that
planet so for instance if a group of eternals
was sent to the scroll homeworld or a world in the
scroll empire the eternals would look like scrolls
and based on starfox's backstory they implied
that thanos rebelled against their eternal's
mission first like he learned about the truth of
the emergence first on titan and was banished by
alars after he tried to get them to kill
half the population to stop the emergence
you're not the only one cursed with knowledge
then after he was gone something happened to a
large he also died and then naming starfox his
successor passing his celestial court to him
and that's how starfox would have become the prime
eternal of his group on titan taking over their
emergence mission but then also himself eventually
rebelling against irish and the judge and escaping
the same way that sersi rebelled after she got the
celestial core from ajak in the next time he shows
up in a movie harry styles shows up as starfox
like during eternals 2 if they do a sequel or some
other mcu space based movie they'll cover more of
his backstory with thanos on titan so eventually
they will tell the rest of that story for those of
you that want to see more of young thanos like the
thinner version of thanos we can call him thinos
but if you have any other questions about starfox
and thanos just write them below in the comments
i might do another video about the celestials in
the cosmic history of the mcu now that the movies
come out so if you have any other video requests
or any other big cosmic questions about the
mcu just write them below in the comments too
everyone click here for that new eternals black
knight deleted scene for kit harington's character
and click here to learn how thanos
save the avengers from the celestials
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!